each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
today I would like to talk about
integrative data mining for drug
discovery using the symmetric work as we
can imagine there's a now incredibly
rich resource of a public and
proprietary information pertinent to
drug discovery at least the Sun
resources taken from the public domain
you can see there has a 64 million
compounds and 16 h 3 bounces from
pubchem and nine menial protein
sequences from swiss porch and 58,000 3d
structures from pdb and what those are
the resources from NPR and pubmed and
also we have an emerging pathway this is
g and phenotype databases so Fitness a
bunch of information one of the great
challenge for us is how way separates
the wheat frontage off and use of of
this information together to discover
the next generation of a treatments so
to do this requires a framework of
integration that includes symmetrix
cross domain data mining and advanced
the determination of irrelevance at our
University were tracking this from a
compulsion trick approach using
aggregative web service firm works and
the symmetric data mining and automated
mining of a journal articles so this
approach is including four layers the
first layers storage it is a
comprehensive information storage
including the symmetrix and metadata so
we have a local databases sieve such
data and we have information generators
like predict models and we have a
traction from generals and network
models so the second layer interface is
to create cama interfaces to stored
information so we have created
cheminformatics verbs wise
infrastructure you can find as much as
the information from our website kim
belgrade rock this sir layer is
aggregation we aggregate verb
devices using RDF and/or excimer so NASA
new year is the interactions to create
kinds of a software for information
exists and storage so we create
integrative data mining choose like
windy as your people will always have a
sim question what will need to know
about this are compound when they have
it for the first time and also they
answer to this question will always give
them a good point to know about it and
also we know the key insights were often
come only when the information from
multiple sources is understood in
aggregate and the multiple sources may
support our conflict with one another by
either way eat the information is very
important so we create this kind of chua
windy which is the prototype aggregate
data mining truth try to a church to
help this question because it will fund
no obverse associations between compound
and biological activities so country we
would like to aggregate four main
resources one is that just in too windy
so like our databases activity related
and predictions and models and documents
including generals and some other verbs
resources so of this just based on works
of us infrastructure so then we need
will provide a chore to get all of the
researcher to understand the compound
understand the context in which the
compound operates and to found a cruise
to help them understand the properties
of the compound maybe they were compound
which they may not have discovered
before so when you will give them just
the use virtual to do some research so
this is our windy version 1 clean
interface it will takes mouse as input
and since these two are windy web
services so we develop device will do
two things once to do similarity search
our local databases another is a cosine
web services
a variable our site after that all the
result will be aggregated in XML as
output so when they were processes x
mark and display the results on the same
page so we have already pub released our
public versions through this link so
right now what we have now is a simmer
which just the carrier part to fund some
relationships between the compound and
activities compounded literature
information directly so we're just
wondering if we can find some more in
further elation ships based on the Exuma
automatically it should be more useful
so we convert xml to a diff and create
the idea of late work to solve this
problem so when diversion choices are
going projector and our chocolates later
so right now I just want to show a
little bit Jean disease relationships we
have built Jean disease relationships
based on the final prid which is
provided by province the pager from well
for bioinformatics group in our school
sophina parade is a matrix of our
predictions of jeans and disease
relationships based on the no
relationships mighty the front
literature and machine learning
predictions so this is the example show
the pre-show day experimentally and
predicted associations of jeans and
malignant deliberately plasm of bristol
kind of a breast cancer so we have a
gene and disease relationship as well so
we would like to add a chemical disease
relationships into windy as well so
first the way to the similarity search
to find the similar compounds which are
active or inactive in the parkin by
oasis and the to find similar drugs from
the drug bag and similar compounds from
the literature then we can go to some
text the information like descriptions
of a pop can bow is this usage of drugs
and titles of journal articles then
based on that we can create a true
candle of our chemical disease
relationships
the first is a director lower which is
the checker text searching to find which
disease are contempt in these attacks
then we can just appoint how to stay
relationships between the compound curve
compound and disease another we creates
the inferred one wheels ago anoche
ontology to fund which go turn the
content in this text and use a goal
allocation to fund which juice
associated with this cotton and use the
phone operator matrix to fund which
disease are social with these genes then
we can fund we can invert the
relationships between the quarry and the
disease so next I just want to show some
cooperating evidence taken from the
windy version one with celexa
doxorubicin as a query compound
doxorubicin is commonly used in any
treatment of a wide range of cancers so
from these chicks that we can see the
doxorubicin is predicted active in NC I
h23 by our NC Emerson and predict models
and also as a similar compound with the
similarities a point in 96 for justice
to be show experimental activity and C
are etched industry in this a particular
Pupkin bio AC also we can fund the
nonspecific humor inhibiting properties
of the doxorubicin is identified by our
predict models and as a similar result
can be found in there in the ontological
maktab text in a similar drug Daniel
Robinson and also they doxorubicin is
predicted to have our toxicity issues
bio talk tree and it is noted in the
ontological image job takes in the
similar track and this is a sound in
such taken from the literature search we
can identify our well-known leukemia
usage from the sermon and database
search and also we can find a listener
no applications of this a similar
compound which is against H
while HIV integrase so from the above
results we can we can find say when the
virtual one just provides automatic
aggregation of the information but it's
realized under manual interpretation of
these outputs and the manual just the
identification the conflicting and
cooperating evidence so then we would
like to create windy version 2 to serve
this problem we create a simple or
ontology to identify this kind of
elements and the relationships based on
the eczema so we can like we can
identify the quarry is similar to day
society which is a Popkin pubchem
company ID and this theory is active
against this a ID which is our pop
compile a society and also we can find
the breast cancers is contingent is a
parking policy so the other so they
other similar rules can be found out
then we can just create synergy RDF
network expand around inquiry then other
if inference engines can be applied and
result can be filtered so this is our
windy or rdf network we can find some
relationships like the quarry is similar
to this charity which is a general you
and this GED is a socio is a general
title and logical number then we can
found the PID which is a PubMed ID and
we can find the article titles also we
can find the quarry similar to the CID
and the city is sushi with the AIT and
for both of the journal title and the
descriptions of the pubchem bioassay we
can find which coaches account really
and which gene disease are related then
we can find some information ships like
Korean social with the general title
parasocial wasted disease and such as
she's between the quarry NZ a ID so then
we employ slew based inference
algorithms to retrieve the new
relationships based on the RDF network
so I have lists the sum of the outputs
is here so we can see the query compound
is associate with a list of a PID and
associate with a list of article title
then we can find the pub the acquired
company is associate with a list of x 0
SE also for the wind aversion to we
would like to add we would just defend
some more inferred relationships based
on the IDF network and we will focus on
the pirate compound and jeans and
disease relationships as will also we
would like to add some advanced
algorithms like automated extraction of
our relationships from the literature
apply digital pubmed abstract and open
access food text and also we will
actuate advanced the concept of a
synergy and relevance of journal
articles incorporating structure and
etre logically similarity and at the
what your predictions based on more
validate models and chemical biological
air a seal it works then this is my
summary just based on what we have done
we can we would like to see the
exploding the complex explosion of a
public and private private data center
done compounds will give a competitive
edge for drug discovery we cannot do
this by playing verbs of ice edge
texture and symmetric verb methods but
it is a very new era there is a lot of
work to be done and when the offers a
new approach to determining the actress
information so strives to look at the
big picture and identify cooperating or
the conflicting informations from models
aces database and publications so nasty
ASA I would like to send Sakura who is
working with me to build a windy version
transaxle II need to fund this project
since Microsoft to give us prior granted
excellent software research give me this
opportunity to print my work here thank
you so much
I have one can Wendy platform of
software is that something that you're
releasing or will provide it can use the
verb survives as well and we also
publish it a version you can just use
this public version as windy I have
showed you there yes and reuse yes he's
also going to configure the display on
his laptop to feel the display I think
it's going to work where do we have a
picture yeah yeah fantastic right okay
hello everyone my name is Mark baulkham
I'm a postgraduate student from the
University of Southampton school of
chemistry and I'm going to talk to you
about extracting NMR spectra and
structural information from PDF
documents on the internet and we feel
that this is a really important problem
to solve because there's a lot of legacy
data out there on the internet and it
could be curated and put to further use
so I'm a computer scientist not a
chemist I don't profess to be one so
i'll introduce NMR for people who
haven't the method before nuclear
magnetic resonance spectroscopy is an
analytical technique used in chemistry
and it exploits the magnetic properties
of certain atoms the ones that we
focused on our hydrogen the protons and
the particular 13 NMR 13 isotope of
carbon
you have to forgive me with terminology
if it's compiler engineering I'm quite
happy to talk for hours but chemistry
anyway so i'm going to show you the
objects of interest very quickly we've
got the spectrum itself which is all
intents and purposes a graph and it has
a scale the spectrum scale and I've
drawn some boxes around it to make it
easier to distinguish and a nice feature
of publications today is that people
will often put the molecular structure
in their data as well so we end up with
this nice graph with an embedded
molecule and the question that was posed
is wouldn't it be nice if we could go
back from this the original data now
there's a bit of a problem here when you
publish NMR spectra or any piece of data
really in a PDF document what you're
doing is making hamburgers you take your
data and you mince it all up and then
you present it as a picture and that's
great don't get me wrong it's wonderful
that we have picked or representations
of things but it's very difficult to use
that picture to do more research you
have to ask the person for their data
sometimes they're reluctant to give it
to you and that's been discussed at
length so I'm not going to go into that
the problems from my perspective are
that this data is not machine readable
and so the information the knowledge
that is there is lost so how can we go
back so there's this neat quote from
Michael Kay who's a bit of a prolific
blogger and he says that converting PDFs
back into XML is a bit like turning
hamburgers back into cows so that's
exactly what we're going to do we start
off with the PDF which is a really
nice-looking hamburger and what we want
to do with the PDF is slowly but surely
collect all the small bits of
information together group them up into
larger bits of information and then
enrich that as XML documents so what
we're left with is a cow now I mentioned
compiler engineering that's exactly how
i became istry but i do know how to
write compilers when I see a stream of
tokens going in a row I look for
regularity and grammars and so what I'm
going to show you is how we've applied
that to extract this information from
PDF
so what are the features of interest
well PDF is a vector format so you
basically got three things you've got
text specified as characters you've got
lines specified as origin and an extent
and you might have something called a
polyline this is just terminology that's
come from PDF documents and that would
be a line with multiple segments so it's
got one origin and then they specify a
lot of extent and so what I've got is
very simple idea with a bit of maths
because I'm sadistic is to have a
bounding rectangle for any feature so if
we have this bounding rectangle we can
start doing useful things and if I go
back up to the first slide if you look
at the bounding rectangles that I've
drawn around the objects we notice
something quite interesting first of all
where two objects intersect we can put
them in a tree as siblings and we can
assert that there is some relationship
between those two objects where two
bounding boxes one is contained within
the other we could assert that there's a
high likelihood that the child object
the box inside the larger box is some
derivative of the parent so we can apply
this and what we're left with is an
abstract syntax tree like so so we
construct a load of bounding boxes and
we group them all together using this
algorithm and what we're left with is
essentially the document object model
but for chemistry papers and we've done
this inside an extensible framework that
I've been building and it allows us to
specify heuristics at the moment to
allow the abstract syntax trees to be
collapsed into objects so we can say
things like a graph axis has a very long
horizontal line this is a really
powerful thing to be able to say because
it allows us to describe the scales and
the spectra themselves in terms of what
they look like on a page so i can start
teaching the i can teach my compiler
essentially how to distinguish between
proton NMR and ir NMR which is quite
useful so future work that we're going
to do is something called an SVM a
support vector machine what you end up
with on each
age if you chop the page up into
constituent rectangles you can do this
arbitrarily or apply clever techniques
you end up with a vector and that vector
just has eat for each component a set of
numbers so the magnitude which would be
the number of occurrences of a
particular feature or possibly the
orientations of lines if you're looking
for molecules and you can start doing
really clever and machine learning
techniques for this hopefully on the
next page right so I'll just show you
very quickly the work that we've
completed my colleague bill brauer penn
state university has done some really
clever work to do with approximating the
curves that i can extract from documents
so the idea is that what I'm going to do
is say this is a particularly juicy
looking hamburger and I have a good idea
of what that hamburger might taste like
and then I can give that hamburger to
bill and what he's got is brilliant
software that uses gaussian mixture
modeling to approximate the curve and
give you a good approximation of the
original data and I'm also working on
connection tables which is where you
take the molecular structure straight
out of the paper and if you look over
here we can actually distinguish between
the stereochemical bonds as well and
we're going to rip the molecules out as
CML documents so you get fully enriched
PDF documents out of this so to conclude
I'm not going to keep you from your
lunch there's a wealth of this
information on the internet and our aim
is to make that available to people as
CML and/or chem so any questions please
I just like to thank very quickly Tony
hey Microsoft or inviting me to talk the
w un or funding all this work and the
other contributors I'm going to have a
drink now as well
all the PDFs that we've used for testing
are in the public domain so providing
you have permission to use that PDF into
work with it then what we're doing is no
different to selecting all the text and
copying and pasting and that information
is essentially already there we're just
converting it into another form we're
actually we're actually working with
PostScript and we convert all our PDF
documents into PostScript to normalize
them and we find that easier to work
with that does have some other drawbacks
but if you buy me a beer I'll discuss
them with you but to all intents and
purposes we take PDF documents and
absolutely yeah but exactly we're
actually collaborating with Peter Marie
Russell's group in Cambridge and they've
got Oscar and ops in which are fantastic
text processes that allow you you can
basically give it a load of character
data and it will extract all of the
chemical entities so all of the
molecular names ok son ok trying to give
them some credit ok so what we're
working with at the moment is having a
nice framework where anything that looks
like text we could give to Oscar to work
with or we could give to any other piece
of software so it's an extensible
framework and anything hopefully will be
possible in the future and we'd love to
work with other domains as well so if
you can teach us how to tell the
computer what your objects of interest
look like we'd be very interested to
work with you and see if our framework
and help you enrich your legacy data as
well
yes yeah yes right
yep we're actually working on a
completely separate note a project
called store link and has another name
called Claudia in Southampton and this
is in cooperation with Edinburgh and
reading and it allows you to do academic
trackbacks essentially so there's a
trackback protocol for blogs where you
can say you know I've made a comment
about your blog post and we're working
on exactly the same thing citations for
converting data so you would be able to
say I've downloaded your spectra and
converted it into this the difficulty is
actually in finding out who to send that
message to so we need to work with the
publishers so that information is
available when I do the enrichment it
would be nice to tell the person
currently all I have is a name and as
you've shown us it's very difficult to
go from the author name to an author
identifier in the consistent way